three two one here we go
hey what's up welcome to winners on a
wednesday i wanna introduce you to a
fabulous lady her name is gemma edens
she's absolutely
killing it at the moment in property and
i thought you'd be able to learn some
nuggets and tips from the lady herself
the lady of the hour gemma thanks so
much for coming to my home hi
thank you thanks for having me now you
were a little bit unsure and hesitant
about doing this because you've been
saying
well why why were you so unsure about
this the amount of people that's going
to see it
oh right okay yeah so i was just a bit
apprehensive about
the amount of people that are going to
see it and how i'm going to be perceived
as well so
why does it matter that lots of people
will see it i don't know i just i just
think it's something to do with me
really i just um
it's hard it's the funny thing is you
you've been on a lot of our training
sessions
you're on samuel 365 you've been to
three crash courses yeah
and when you're on the training programs
you
will always speak up or i'll say
something and you'll have a question or
you'll want to say oh actually i just
sold a deal yesterday and can i
add to that and you'll share yeah and
hundreds and hundreds of people who are
on these training programs are really
inspired by you
so i basically got bullied into having
you on the show like all these people
are like
we need gemma on the show you know we
need to hear from gemma
so i'm really glad that you made the
trip down from from lincoln
to be here today you're doing
ridiculously well why don't you just
give a little bit of a background
into who you are and why you wanted to
become a property investor entrepreneur
yeah so um i kind of i've always been in
property
um i bought my first house when i was 21
and
i bought it a year before the recession
so i did everything
the wrong way it was it was not good um
you know i lost a lot of money on that
and
when i stumbled across one of your
videos once um
it gave me an opportunity to put it
right so the money that i'd lost
previously through property and that i
really enjoyed um i just got the buzz
and thought
the buzz is back i want to get back on
the property ladder and and get into it
full time
but yeah i was working so i couldn't 100
do it what was that first video because
and what was going on what made you sad
okay so my
friend was buying a house and she was
using a help to buy
scheme um grant from the government yeah
and i just wanted to look into it a bit
more because i thought i want to
get a house and uh so i googled like
pros and cons of
the government helped buy scheme
dangerous thing to google
your video came up absolutely slate in
it but
i liked your views and i related so much
with how you spoke
um everything everything that you were
saying in it just
related and resounded so much with me
that i ended up binge watching a lot of
your videos
i got so much hype for that video really
yeah oh i really liked it well yeah
because
i was basically saying help to buy is a
sham
yeah and i think it's actually helped to
sell it's to help the rich not to help
the poor yeah and all these people that
have invested in the help to buy scheme
were upset with me because they're like
i didn't help somebody scream and how
it's the same as when i say things like
you know don't just go to university
blindly
you know be careful because it it
sometimes isn't the best thing to do
and then people have just finished
universe who are upset with me because
they've just spent
27 000 pounds in three years of their
life studying something to get a degree
and it's like a bit of a raw nerve yeah
so it's interesting that you watched it
and thought actually
no i thought you i thought you taught
sense yeah that's that's why
i then started looking into a bit more
and you know your background
and and how you came into property in
that and how did you lose money on that
first deal
i mean it 26 000 it got down valued
right so i bought it for 96 500 and
in the end it was i think it went for
like 60 odd thousand
you bought it to live in and then sold
it bought it to live in and then became
a landlord
because i was in the military at the
time so
we bought it lived in it and then moved
about
in the military so um yeah i had all
sorts of tenants in it and
it just became a massive hassle and
the amount of money that we was getting
only just covered the mortgage
yeah um and then we had to obviously
paid landlords insurance on top of that
so it was actually costing us to have
the house that's funny though because
you i don't know you're in the military
that's crazy but if buying a property
without knowing what you're doing can
actually be a bad move it's not a case
of just
buy property and make money and
everything's okay
there is there is skills to it there is
an art to it finding the right kind of
deal i didn't have that i didn't have
the skills
all the knowledge so i was i was a young
21 year old and preferred
i just wanted to get on the house you
know i was always brought up to do
things the right way
you know um and by right way i mean
traditional
find a guy settle down get a house get a
dog
get married and that's exactly what i
wanted to do but it didn't kind of pan
out that way so
i did it all the steps up to that but
then i went down the divorce route
right another interesting thing you
bought a house what year was it 2009.
seven 2007. oh right yeah exactly
right just before 2008 yeah and at the
time of 2007 no one knew the crash was
coming
and then bang the crash came but there
was other people buying a lot of people
that lost money i mean i was buying
houses in 2009.
birmingham when the crash was happening
still yeah because actually 2008 the
crash came but
the housing market wasn't really
affected until the year after in most
areas
but because my cash flow was good on my
hmos and stuff i didn't care that the
values dropped
yeah i was like great i lost 30 grand
but i'm making a grand a month on that
house
yeah but you lost money but the house
wasn't even breaking even
so just as a liability yeah because the
rental value
was was low for that area yeah um and we
got
i mean i bought near an raf camp which
was where i used to work
um and uh the only tech because it was a
village the only tenants that we could
really get in that property
were um people that were on social
housing like benefits so
um so they bartered with us a lot to
come down
on on that kind of the rent so we'd
rather have tenants than no tenants
and there was a lot of void periods we
we went through maybe three or four
years of
um you know six months in and then three
months of
of nothing where you're paying council
tax and that so
it's not good so you spent time in the
military when we
first connected in around about
september october time
2020 yeah you were a project manager
yeah you were earning good money
yeah in quite a high powered job yeah um
so what happened um
so obviously as we all know corona that
had a massive impact on everything from
march
last year we all had to work from home
um
and i think because of the impact um
the company that i worked for were it
was a mixture of
permanent employees and contractors but
predominantly contractors because if
anything was happening to the business
as a fail-safe the contractors would go
first they're easier to get rid of
and we were on six monthly rolling
contracts so every six months my
contract would get renewed
as a contractor you get paid more so you
you don't get the benefits of working
with the company but you get the
benefits of the highest salary yeah
um so it was a rolling contract and
i felt pretty safe and i actually tried
to get permanent for quite a while
um but there was never an opportunity
for me
so yeah i think about
i think it was about november october
october november time
they reduced my contract down to three
months and that was across the board
so everybody went on to three monthly
contracts
so my contract was due to end
in january um and i didn't think
anything of it i just thought yeah
it's corona everyone's getting affected
they're just doing something to protect
the the company as a whole um and then
i got handed my notice out of nowhere
just after
christmas and i was shocked because i
didn't see it coming
at all yeah yeah so um
yeah i i got a phone call one day
from my two bosses at the time
just basically saying we can't renew
your contract and at the end of january
you're gone and this was like
i think it was like the second week of
january so
i was due to leave the 28th of january
geez
and how did that how did that make you
feel at the time i cried
a lot um because the thing
uh i don't want to get emotional but
i had like a difficult time before
getting into that job
um because my marriage broke down and i
was on benefits and i thought
i don't want to be in that situation
again yeah and i had this property
um you know the training that we was
doing
i had that on the side and i thought if
that doesn't work then i'm going to be
on benefits with my little boy and i
just thought i can't i've lived
such a great life over the last five
years and it petrified me thinking
am i going to have to claim benefits
despite that there's nothing wrong with
doing that and we've all
been in a situation like that at some
point in our life
i just couldn't do that to myself again
because i felt
when i was in that time it was such a
difficult time
um and i think i had my moment
for about 12 hours and then i said
no i'm not gonna go in that deep hole
i'm to make this work
yeah the following day i sold my first
deal
incredible incredible so and i want to
find out exactly what happened
with that and i bet a lot of people
because you'd been
kind of like tinkering a bit with the
training you've been on a few of the
calls
we knew you i knew you yeah from
when did we when did you first connect
with me for actual rather than watching
youtube
when did you first go on a webinar or
something okay so uh
following watching youtube i don't know
whether
it came up as an advertisement on
youtube that you was doing free training
you was doing these webinars at the time
and it was a lease option agreement one
i didn't have a clue what it was like
honestly i didn't had no clue what it
was and i thought
he's doing some training it's free i
want to get onto that webinar
um but yeah i don't know whether it was
on the youtube or whether i actually
went onto your website but i saw this
training and i signed up straight away
and it was for i'm sure it was the first
of october
and i went on it and uh
it was it was not like the zooms are now
where you could freely speak it was just
chat and i remember seeing you and
russell yeah
um and he was given this training and
russell was like going through the
questions and things like that
and i think i just kept on being visible
in the chat
yeah like i'm jeremiah and gemma lincoln
lincoln you know just
really getting involved and i remember
yes yeah
i remember saying to my partner if i
keep being a visible person he's going
to notice me
and i don't know why i wanted your
attention but i did yeah and i thought i
just
i i can sense something here i know i
know
well i'm gonna be sat here right now
attention is the first thing you need to
get in business yeah get people's
attention and then you can then
promote your products or services or
whatever it might be be loud
yeah or be quiet you know get noticed
yeah so
that was the very first thing yeah
you're coming on all the different free
trainings
you're letting you're letting me and
everybody know hey i'm here i've arrived
i'm on the webinar folks so we knew who
you were
and and and you know you did a little
bit of the free training
and and whatever but you haven't done
any deals but you knew the world of
property investing you knew
why at this time in october november
time when you felt like you had a
safe secure job you were getting paid
very well
why did you feel the need to be coming
on these webinars in your evenings and
weekends
what was the purpose i'm glad you've
brought that up because
my partner chris um knows and can vouch
for this
um a couple of years ago i said this
is not the life for me and he and he
didn't get it
and i said look hear me out and actually
a couple of my old work colleagues will
vouch for me as well
i said i'm gonna be a millionaire one
day i know it sounds crazy but i
am i'm gonna i feel like this isn't my
destiny this isn't
and they said you know this only like
hit me like a couple of years ago and it
just kept coming
in and out of my mind like that this
mundane get up go to work
such a rat race you know kids at school
taking them swimming
you know it's not for me i just feel
like there's something different
right that's why i took a risk
and i won't say it was a risk i took a i
took a big gamble to
give up all my nights yeah to
put myself into this because it felt
right right and i can't explain that
it felt the right thing to do that's
really interesting i'm glad to ask the
question so
so you're in a decent job and you're
happy yeah you thought there's something
more yeah you know i you felt destined
for something great
yes and you started giving up your
evenings and weekends
going on trainings a lot of it was free
you joined samuel 365.
but then boom you got made we're not
ready redundant but you your contract
ended yeah and you suddenly had no job
and it's like
really interesting because i really
believe everything happens for a reason
and it's almost like you're being
prepared for that moment in time
and that's what everyone said um i
moaned
a lot before uh christmas
that i felt like i didn't have enough
time to do my passion
because i got really after doing the
training i got so heavily invested in it
that i was really passionate about it
and
every single day i woke up and didn't
want to turn on my pc
to do work despite that i had to because
that's what i was getting paid for
but i couldn't wait until half past two
every day to go on viewings and to get
in touch with my investors that i'd
started to build up
um and you were you weren't just
watching
webinars you were actually implementing
yeah and stuff even while you're in your
job
yeah which is really interesting and it
was hard work because
i got a family and um you know
i had to pick up william from school and
you know be mum
said mom heart be girlfriend hat be
daughter hat
um and um and then as soon as william
was in bed
that was it whatever training i could
get on whatever training i could do
whatever zoom calls i was involved i was
on right move i was
you know sending out um messages on
gumtree or
everything i was up to 11 yeah every
night and you know just looking
and and doing what i needed to do to try
and get something set up
when you told me that you had lost your
job it must have been after the 12 hour
crying stint
because maybe because you said to me
yeah because you you said i've just been
i think it was like the day after yeah
you said i've just been let go
of my job however i'm pleased
i actually think that it's a blessing in
disguise is what you said to me and you
were like
now i'm gonna go absolutely go for it in
property
so you said within 24 hours you then
made some money in property yeah tell me
about that
so during the christmas period of
me being off work i was on heavily on
right move looking at areas
and um just doing a bit of due diligence
and i found a property
that i thought the the actual room plan
looked amazing for a hmo and it was a
four
three four bedroom um and i was looking
at the floor plans and i was like
this could be a seven bed seven bed
commercial valuation that's all i kept
on thinking yeah
and i was like 7 hm a commercial and i
started doing the figures
and at that point the calculator that i
was working on
i'd never seen a minus before and i
didn't know what it meant so i was
texting anthony what does this mean it's
a minus
and he was like buzzing that is a hot
deal
it's infinite return i was like really
and i was like
what's that mean and he's like seriously
go for it and i was like okay
so i sort of go through the figures and
everything and i was like
oh my god it's an infinite return pull
all your money out and then 19
000 just by all the figures that i've
gone through and i thought
yeah i'm putting i'm putting an offer in
there so negotiate
negotiated down from 95 000
to 87 500. yeah nice and specific i like
it yeah
yeah well there was a bit of up and down
and i never go for
right on now like some of the agents
like laugh at me and i'm like you know
87 775 and then i forget what i've
actually offered
yeah um and then yeah
so so we got it for that and uh
i wasn't compliant at that time and i
thought okay i need to
to talk to somebody about this so
anthony love him got so much stuff
doesn't know anthony's one of the
mentors of samuel 365 community and
we've got lots of mentors on there
but anthony's and he's one of the
managers obviously very very successful
he he's he's supported me so much i've
got a lot a lot of love for him
um and he said right i want you to do
because he knew that i could do it and
he could see it in us and i've already
like
i'd already spoke to him loads of time
we'd already met on one of the deals
that we'd done before
um and uh he says right i'll send it out
my investor list
but as soon as the text messages start
coming in
that people are interested in the
property you call them
yeah so he just sent it out to his
investor list and then he literally sent
me a screenshot property one property
one property one and i was like
oh my god what are we doing um so i had
a quick chat with him
picked me up he said you can do this you
don't need me you can do this
got on the phone and i sold it straight
away like there was
there was no com there was no like um
he he understood everything that would
said and he was like i'm really happy
with it i just want to sign
yeah i was like and i couldn't believe
it and i was like really oh my god i'm
happy that you're happy and you
you put the trust in me and he's like i
want you to project manage seeing as
you know i've been a project manager i'd
just um you know
we're doing our own development on the
property that we've got at the moment so
i have got a little bit of the the
knowledge needed
to to help with um overseeing
all the projects so yeah that all
happened
the next day after you got my redundancy
that's crazy
how much money do you make on that deal
uh in total
six and a half thousand that's
incredible so the sourcing fee plus
project manager's fee sold project
manager's fees separately now that was
the start of a little empire for you
which has happened
very quickly over the last few months
because you sold that deal and i
remember
at the time you celebrated you shared
with all the community you're like oh my
gosh
i've just been made redundant but now
i've just solved this deal yeah
it's bittersweet yeah absolutely but
then you just ran with it
yeah and you just kept selling deals and
get because because you know
you spent three months immersing
yourself in training you've gone through
the deal finding extravaganza so you had
a fine deal
yeah and the rent to rent accelerator
celebrations
yeah so you do quite a lot of training
yeah uh online all virtually is our very
first time meeting in person today
which is great
yeah but it's it's um it's just crazy
that that happened so
fast i mean now you know it's it's it's
it's several months now after you
um after you've been made it ten weeks
how are things going generally
yeah so busy yeah very busy um
the next couple weeks gonna be really
exciting because we're completing
financially on
a lot of the deals that i've sold over
the last couple of
couple of months so um so yeah what did
you do last month
uh in money or in deals or
uh just over ten thousand that's
incredible
yeah i mean that's presumably that's
more than you were making as a project
manager
way more yeah yeah i was uh
1600 in my normal job crazy yeah
which at the time you thought that's
great to now
yeah crazy money yeah how does it feel
to go from 1600 to 10 000 pounds a month
um i don't think it's sunk in yet and i
haven't changed my lifestyle
right so i'm still living like i lived
before
yeah but the money that i've accumulated
and putting elsewhere
and reinvesting it so and that's the the
smart thing if i were you
i would be keeping your lifestyle
reasonably low
putting all of the money back into the
business
yeah when i said back into the business
i'm talking about on your
um um on deals on your own deals
yeah on rent to rent and things like
that on your websites
on more on further training yeah
constantly putting it back into your
business
rather than upping because it's so easy
to just up your lifestyle a little bit
and then and then suddenly it's like oh
well i've not got money to invest now
do you know yeah and i'm i'm a humble
person anyway i come from a humble
background
and i don't want to change who i am as a
person
so yeah it'll be nice not to have to
worry and i don't have to worry
that's that's the main thing i don't
have to worry but i want to build an
empire i don't want to just coast
like i want to to be known as as a
business woman
and be taken seriously and for everybody
to know that
gemma means business and she she's good
at it i think people think that
dear i think so i mean the speed of your
implementation i think is
is really interesting yeah like when you
and and that's what
why we gel so well together because the
way the way my training
is set out is that you take action as
you go
yes and that's how you are i'll see it
you'll be on a crash course
i mean you've been on three now and
you'll be on the phone
doing deals while you're oh yeah yeah i
remember that
sold a deal when i was on the crash
course yeah yeah what happened tell me
about it oh
right so um i think you've actually
picked on me
because i didn't have my no
no i think i did have my thing on but i
think you was
all of a sudden i was on the phone i
remember my bit i'm in my bit
i'm talking i'm running a a training
program
you're on the phone but you were like
you were like not just on the phone but
you were
like excited like pacing and stuff so i
just said to everybody i was like
i have to find out what's going on there
yeah so i called you out like
gemma come and share with everybody
what's happening because i we i had no
idea
yeah you know i just thought it looked
like you're just excited to be on the
phone somebody and you were just like
one minute one minute
yeah and i thought i'll leave it and
then you came back on and told us yeah
which was
i just sort of deal so and i can't
really remember what that deal was
but yeah you sold it anyway yeah yes
i was like i remember you just going
german gemma and i'm like
i'm selling a deal yeah but but now
you're all compliant
yes 100 you've got your website set up
yeah what is your website
um it is eden's property uh dot co dot
uk
edens property dot com uk yeah sure name
is eden so that makes sense
yeah but i think the speed of your
implementation is the thing that makes
you
winning because i mean when you go
through the training presumably you're
just implementing
yeah so so that's how i i'm a see and do
so i'll watch a bit and then i'll go
right i'm gonna go off and do that
um and then if i come to something where
i don't know the answer i'm like it's
going to be in the training so then i go
back so i'm a bit of a back and forth
with training
and you know i've gone over modules over
and over again because
i know the answers are in there yeah um
and if i if i haven't got it
the thing is the way i work is and i've
done this
with like job interviews i'll go in and
i'll say i'm like a sponge i do soak up
the knowledge
and and i feel like i've i've tucked
this like a duct to water
and it just feels comfortable you know
and doing the training i'm like yeah
that makes sense and
you know and and now i'm helping other
people in the same situation
so um you know other sources
or so people that are wanting to source
are coming to me and asking me questions
and i feel so confident to to give them
the answers
and help them through it and that's the
thing and that's why you're here because
this is
like what we've got with 365 it's a
community yeah so
yeah you've got the training but then if
you if
you're still stuck you book a call with
a mentor yeah but then you've also got
the community
one another yeah so you've formed a
right little click butter with some of
the ladies as well yeah well we've
actually got our own team and they'll
love that i've shouted them out so we're
called the property a team
and there's 14 of us and the reason why
we've done it is i think was waiting for
a zoom call to start
and i think you'd had a few problems
technical difficulty
so we created our own zoom call yeah and
start off with it was very
professional talking about property you
know was all there fully dressed now
we're just in dressing gowns all of us
are laid in bed we're chatting about a
property
we have a bit of a social and you know
what we've we've completely gelled
as a group and we have got the ultimate
jv
amongst us you know we we can joint
venture on things where
you know i've co-sourced with a couple
of the guys out of there and
helped each other out and the the
absolute
mountain of knowledge in that group is
and support
is just incredible so that's great so
thanks for bringing us together because
i mean lifelong friendships well that's
what this is about yeah you know and
and it's about it's about people it's
about the power of people
and and if you do it alone you try and
google the answers to everything not
only are you going to get a ton of stuff
that's
all contradicting information written up
by 22 year old kids that have never
actually done it all these articles the
training is
only part of it it's also the community
the support the mentorship
um talk to me as well about because you
haven't just done
the training on deal finding and selling
you've also done the rent to rank
program
yes um rentman accelerator yep how was
that and what's happened since
okay so when i did it
i'll be honest i didn't like the
strategy you didn't like the rent event
strategy
no i just didn't i just didn't get it i
think that's what it is and i was like
no i'm not doing that tell me why you
didn't like it i'm very interested
um i couldn't understand how somebody
would just
want to rent their house out to somebody
else without
them doing it so hmo
essay i didn't know why the landlord
would not want to just rent it out as a
hmo themself
right why on earth would they give it to
me to manage
when they could just do it themselves
and that's why i couldn't get my head
around
until i started implementing it and
building up
relationships with landlords and
securing memphis
rent to rent accommodation so
um i started watching the rent to rent a
little bit more
and seeing other people's journeys and
talking to a lot of people and i thought
out of the two
i'm more inclined to go for service
accommodation because i love staying
away and i love hotels
and i thought if i could create
something that i enjoy
staying in maybe other people want to
stay in
you know if i if i make it you know
something that i like to my tastes and
and that and then it was the whole
getting to a landlord
who will want me to do that and is
you know is happy for me to manage their
their
property um i spoke to emma callan
gorgeous lover to bits she's got so much
knowledge and she's
she's a master in service accommodation
and
she we got on really well again for
anyone doesn't know another mentor
because it's like that's the thing
people think that it's my training and
it's my
actually oh i put it together but but
the training is not just me there's a
whole
lot of people yeah of mentors i know the
connections that you have you make
with all the different mentors and you
know it's just it's just incredible so i
spoke to emma and she's amazing
um and uh and i i felt like
i wanted to repeat what she had done
yeah because
you know she's she's just storming this
and
a lover um so literally
my first message on gumtree got me a
viewing
and um and i was i was like
oh wow i told all my property a team
i've got a viewing on my first rents
around service accommodation
perfect location in lincoln uh close to
the castle and cathedral
it's an apartment and again watched all
the training ricky
set another mentor um and speaker he
said two bedrooms do better than you
know
three and that so i found a two-bedroom
apartment
close to the city uh center um with city
views
and went and viewed it and it was
absolutely perfect
it needed a little bit of work um but
the landlord was actually happy to
refurbish it for me amazing so
i was like okay so i said i explained
the strategy i explained
how it would work we went through a
little bit of negotiation on price
i got a really good deal on it um from
what he was looking for
so the first six months i actually got a
discount on um
on what on the what i think he'd put it
up for like
i think it was 7.95 and i've got it for
six
to five a month incredible for six
months and then 650.
nice that's really good yeah so how much
profit
are you expecting to make on that per
month um 80
occupancy rate it's about 1200 a month
wow
i know that's great and i'm gonna
self-manage because
um i want to learn the ropes myself
because i feel like i can't train
someone without knowing how to do it
myself
i can't trust somebody else a service
combination manager
if i don't know what needs to be done
first so i want to do it first myself
that's so important that you know how to
do it because
again if you're trying to train your
team to do um
like like like if you're trying to train
your team how to manage a service
accommodation property but you've never
done it yourself
yeah how can you they'll pull the wall
over your eyes exactly they'll tell you
it takes two hours when it takes ten
minutes
yeah so i think what you're doing is
you're getting your hands really dirty
yeah doing the deal sourcing now doing
rent to rent
becoming a master at it yeah and then
and i know your goal is to be a
millionaire
you can then scale and start employing
people and
having a proper a proper empire so and
that rent to rent i mean that that okay
that's all sorted and complete and
you've got that one which is in early
stages
but you've since then gone on to get
more rent around yeah
so um i had a really good conversation
with the landlord
um we i pick up the keys for this one
um this saturday that's it very
it's very fresh yeah yeah very fresh and
um he already has another apartment that
he lets out to another corporate let
company
yeah um i don't know who they are but he
didn't like certain things
that were done with that corporate let
company so he said once the term is
finished with
their with that company he wants to give
it to me right
he also has another property and he said
when the tenants leave that i can have
that one as well
yeah so i was like wow this is this is
incredible
um and then he also said i have been on
your website and seen what you've
what you do um i have got another
four or five friends that we've got a
little pot together of of money and we
want to invest
so we're going to have a business
meeting soon
with his friends and to talk about what
requirements they've got so
from one message on gumtree i've got
one definite service accommodation
two in the pipeline and six investors
absolutely awesome yeah how does it feel
amazing
amazing i i still can't believe that
it's it's happening but
as soon as i pick up the keys on
saturday i just can't wait to get in the
mood of right
design and yeah but he's completely
renovated the house for me he's put new
carpets in
he's painted the walls he he actually
asked me how i wanted it
i wanted the garden and yeah it's so it
was it was such a good relationship that
was built and i think going forward it's
going to be amazing
now working for yourself and doing your
deal sourcing and your rent events and
everything that you're doing
what's the strongest reason that you're
doing this what is it that gets you out
of bed excited in the morning
um the chase
yeah i like the fast-pacedness of it and
you know going
out and getting something i'm really
target driven and
um from a personal point of view
i can take my little boy to school and
pick him up every day yeah
i can work my work life around my family
life
and that's that's really precious to me
um
but i think i remember when i first saw
my first deal and i said to anthony oh
what do i do
now and he went go out and get another
one because i was thinking more like
celebrate he's like no go and get
another one
and it changed my mindset straight away
and i was like he's got a point
let's get on it let's do it so now
getting up every day
like mondays is just the perfect day for
me i don't know why i seem to sell all
my deals on mondays um
i actually you know secure things on
mondays i just
monday's a really good day for me and
most people dread mondays yeah
i know i hate it i absolutely hated
mondays
i love mondays now it's my favorite day
that's awesome because it's a day where
everything is done like and i think you
know if you go in
hard and the first day like yes i'm
going to get this done i'm going to get
that done and
yeah yeah tell a live shift though for
you being full time in property
and previously just having a job it is a
massive
life shift i'm doing more hours now
i bet but now you're getting rich
yourself yeah i'm doing
that's that's just a byproduct of it
like i'm not
i'm really humble and not it's not about
that for me i just
i really enjoy doing it i really enjoyed
i can't explain how
happy i am now yeah then i was before
like my life's totally different and
what's the vision what's the long-term
plan
um so my partner is a builder
yeah i shouldn't have said that he's a
bricklayer because he'll kill me for
saying he's a builder
he's a bricklayer but he is a man of all
trades so he can do
anything um you know he's just put velox
windows in
in our extension he's not afraid of
anything but
he he builds houses for a living
and i would love to buy land
and have him build the houses because
you know i love what he does
and um it's for him to be able to like
work on his own terms and not work for a
big building company yeah
so we want to go in hard together doing
this and and build
our own houses and it it's really handy
to have a bricklayer
as a partner because land i can source
yeah and the saucer you know we've got
structural engineers that we know and
we've got architects that we know
he's got the skills to to build it we've
we've got a power team
so what do you think what did you think
of me building houses
on your patch yeah i know as soon as i
i went i remember going around there i
said it because as soon as the youtube
video came out
i was like right i know where that is so
i remember going around there and i sent
you a picture with a thumbs up
yeah you remember and i sent you a
picture your house wasn't
yeah right and how's that brilliant
location because it is a really good
location
you know and um i like how you got them
all on there
like because no one everyone said that
you couldn't do it and it worked you
know it's smart it's brilliant
um for anyone that's wondering what is
this samuel 365 like you've gone through
that you're one of the most active
members on there yeah you've got
hundreds of members
what is it and how does it work okay so
i mean
firstly the first word that springs to
mind is community
straight away because it if you can
imagine a load of like-minded people
in one place um that's what it is
we're all bouncing off each other we
have weekly zoom calls
and then you've got the training that
comes with that
um but i'm in it because of the
community
yeah like i've done the training now i
can go on and go on to the
more advanced training but i still want
to stay with the 365 because of the
community
i look forward to wednesdays you know
when we're we're on the zoom calls every
night
and um finding out what people have done
and
the the connections that come from that
i mean i'm already booked up for
for friday and monday to have calls with
people from 365 just to talk about
sourcing and properties that they may
have but the 365
is it's just without that i won't be
where i am now so i'm really glad that
you created that because i couldn't get
to any live
well yeah we created it during lockdown
yeah and we just said you know what
let's just offer unlimited
mentoring calls it's 95 pound a month
you can do it for a week for a pound to
try out
and it's just blown up so yeah thank you
for being a a founding member of that
because you joined
reasonably early on yes when you first
started and we've grown and developed a
lot since then and also just massive
congrats
you know for what your thank you
everything you're doing is amazing what
will be your final piece of advice to
someone watching this is thinking i
really want to get started
um i want to start making some money i
want to start getting into property
maybe they've got a job
loads of money what are the exact next
steps i should do
um so first things first you need the
training like that is
a must without the knowing what to do
you're never going to be able to
implement it
but also the connections made from the
training you need that you need that
support group you need to start
building an investor list you start
getting your name out there
um but i would do exactly what i've done
so join up make yourself visible yeah
um start adding value to people's posts
if you've done a little bit of the train
say you've joined up you've done a
little bit of the training
um if you know the answer start helping
other people
because if you help people the
connections and what comes from that i
mean i remember posting
on someone's uh post on facebook on the
365
um the face property investors with
samuel
lewis i think that facebook group is um
and added something to help another
person out and i got a couple of
investors from that yeah because they've
seen that
i know what i'm talking about and i've
i've helped somebody and
and they like the fact that you've
helped somebody else out you're not
doing it for personal gain you're not
being spammy
so do the training have confidence you
can do this if i can do it
anybody can do it honestly it's you know
it's great
absolutely amazing well hey thank you so
much for coming to the house i'm
really excited i know for you this is
just the very very beginning so i'm
really excited about getting you back on
maybe in 12 months time when you
hit that millionaire status yes you know
mad mad congrats
thank you anybody watching this i think
you'll agree that gemma is extremely
inspirational so please do me and
general favor
smash the like button and also share
this video around share this with your
friends with your family
with your colleagues if you want to see
more interviews like this
every single week i interview one of my
students on this channel it's called
winners on a wednesday and you can see
the entire playlist up right here
also please don't forget to subscribe to
the youtube channel you can do that over
here
and if you'd like to join samuel 365
community or join a property investors
crash course
i will leave links where you can do that
in the description starting from
one pound it's incredible check it out
and i look forward to seeing you
on the other side
you